if Trump was the nominee let alone won  the election but even if Trump was the  GOP nominee it's exactly what we deserve  right now with the system here is a part  of me that would love to set track win  I'd love to see Trump be the Republican  nominee and run for president as their  as the revenant I'd say to us a guy  because I'm a huge campaign finance  reform person I'd say this is exactly  what your money has destroyed the  American political system all these guys  are like so you are endorsing Donald  Trump as a NASCAR drivers with stickers  on yeah they know who owns that right  thank you I'll sense endorsing Trump you  know that goes with Democrat or  Republican Hillary  all of them across the board are owned  by somebody they're owned by somebody  it's the system you have to raise money  and then you become you got to raise  sick amounts of money